salut les menthe à l'eau avec un os je
regardais depuis deux jours passés dans
les tendances de youtube de vidéos et de
squeeze une de as milk scène qui parle
des tops commentaires et la question
c'est pourquoi on veut être en top
commentaires je vais vous le dire c'est
pour les 1/2 refine générique vraiment
en voyant passer ces vidéos je me suis
mais pourquoi les gens veulent être en
top commentaire est en fait je sais
pourquoi c'est pour vraiment la molécule
du bonheur les endorphines
c'est une molécule qu'on dégage en
faisant du sport en mangeant du chocolat
en ayant un orgasme
c'est une gratification naturel que nous
donne notre cerveau pour nous drogués et
pour nous rendre heureux
vous connaissez forcément ce moment où
ça fait au trop bien et c'était pas
l'orgasme que je faisais au gai mais on
reçoit aussi cette molécule quand on
fait quelque chose de compliqué quand on
a un objectif c'est un stimulant aussi
d'aller vouloir la chercher c'est pour
ça que le cerveau la secrète c'est pour
nous stimuler aller chercher cette
molécule est en 2014 et même les
quelques années qui ont suivi il ya eu
plusieurs études intéressantes à ce
sujet en rapport avec les réseaux
sociaux quel est notre rapport aux
réseaux sociaux et bien parfois rien que
le fait de voir qu'on a une nouvelle
notification peut déclencher ça et quand
on voit le que le nombre de laïcs
augmente sur facebook alors là c'est
l'euphorie dans notre tête c'est le
carnaval c'est la grande droguerie away
fabien une étude mais bien douté source
mais j'ai mes sources mais en fait je ne
vais pas rentrer dans ce système de tous
les youtube heures qui justifie par des
sources internes est déjà parce que les
sur ses pas qu'internet c'est des
bouquins c'est de l'expérience et des
conférences des formations d'une manière
assez drôle quand moi je donne une
formation et qu'on utilise que j'ai dit
en formation comme source
on n'a pas demandé à ce moment là ma
source quand j'ai fait la formation
enfin ça c'est drôle principalement les
sources de ce que je connaissais pas de
ce que je suis en train de vous dire à
bienne de l'eau à sucer le yoyo state
university vision site internet vous
pouvez les consulter toutes les études à
loisir sur news point e s du point e d
en tout cas c'est explique cette envie
d'être en top commentaires dans les
commentaires youtube ouf
pour être tout en haut parce que quand
on est top commentaire forcément il ya
une gratification il ya un sentiment en
fait qu'un petit peu lié à l'ego qu'un
autre comportement social qui vient de
la comparaison avec l'autre sur les
réseaux sociaux chose qu'on avait à la
base dans le naturel mais qui a été
amplifié par les réseaux sociaux et qui
fait que à hordain du beau dehors mais
c'est très éphémère en plus et quelques
instants mais là vous vous dites mais
oui mais voulait youtuber vous demandez
toujours aussi des pouces
oui c'est vrai moi le premier je
rappelle à chaque fin de vidéo
déjà parce que là c'est une étude de l
ue
pub qui montre que si on ne rappelle pas
l'engagement alors dans ces cas là les
gens n'y pensent pas forcément la grande
majorité silencieuse celle qu'on appelle
la majorité silencieuse
même si elle a aimé elle ne va pas
laïque et alors que quelqu'un qui n'a
pas aimé va forcément pensé à 10 l'ex
zaïre pas de problème c'est aussi le
principe du bon restaurant c'est à dire
que quand tu as bien aimé un restaurant
tu va en parler à une personne quand
t'as pas aimer un restaurant tout va en
parler à 10 personnes donc si les
youtuber demande souvent les pouces en
fin de vidéo ils l'associent pas
toujours à leur propre ego même si c'est
vrai je lave ou ça fait vraiment plaisir
c'est aussi un bon moyen pour voir si la
vidéo qu'on a fait à la plus ou pas et
s'il faut qu'on continue dans cette
direction c'est à dire on n'a pas
beaucoup d'indicateurs sur youtube sur
une vidéo de 50 millions va avoir 400
commentaires c'est pas assez pour être
un bon indicateur les pouces sont un bon
indicateur
et après effectivement il ya des
interactions mieux les vidéos sont
référencés mais ça j'ai envie de vous
dire vous le savez en fait depuis le
départ ça c'est sûr et certain
non c'est l'indicateur quand même qui
prime effectivement le plaisir personnel
de voir que ça vous a plu mais je
reviens quand même à tous ces trucs de
vouloir passer en toc commentaires de
vouloir avoir plus de like sur facebook
d'être recrutée à mort sur twitter en
même temps sur quoi d'autre que twitter
est trop tout et je suis stupide c'est
parce que les réseaux sociaux aussi ont
augmenté je voulais dit il ya quelques
secondes le facteur de comparaison avec
l'eau c'est-à-dire qu'on on voit les
photos passer des autres les photos de
vacances des autres et on a envie de ça
et en fait ça nous rend tristes
ça c'est terrible a d'ailleurs si on
voit passer le poste de quelqu'un qui a
beaucoup plus de like ses propres poste
alors ça nous rend tristes ça nous rend
un petit peu envieux alors qu on oublie
que si ça se trouve il ya une semaine
c'est l inverse
c'est juste l'instant présent qui compte
gagne 6 cas parler pour sa de pulsion
scopique c'est vraiment intéressant oui
mais ce qui est la psy c'est bénédicte
vidaillet acheter son livre s'ils
voulaient le voir c'est pas disponibles
en sources sur internet la pulsion
scopique c'est une définition de l'envy
suggérée par la vue c'est en voyant
quelque chose que l'envié la plus forte
et pas forcément en la mentalité en
outre intellectualisant c'est en voyant
quelque chose qu'on a envie de ça la
pulsion scopique donc forcément via
l'écran via les réseaux sociaux
la pulsion scopique aller au tas qui
elle se réveille tout le temps spinoza
parler des passions tristes c'est
exactement ce qui se passe avec certains
tops commentaires youtube avec les
facebook et twitter les instants ils ont
tendance à démultiplier les sentiments
dans vie de tristesse et de solitude
alors j'ai deux choses à vous dire à ce
sujet la première chose que j'ai à vous
dire c'est que n'oubliez pas que ce
n'est jamais la vraie vie moi par
exemple ce que je publie ce
facebook c'est que les trucs cool qui
m'arrive je mets des jolies filles je
vous fais des blagues mais je dis pas
quand ça va pas et la plupart d'entre
vous vous faites pareil donc forcément
c'est pas une comparaison de la vraie
vie qu'on fait sur facebook sur twitter
sur instagram sur les réseaux sa
n'oubliez jamais ça c'est très important
ce n'est pas un reflet on donne juste un
petit prisme et c'est celui qu'on a
envie de donner qu'on maîtrise et la
deuxième chose c'est toujours par
rapport aux endorphines les endorphines
c'est pas mal en soi au contraire c'est
un super stimulant prenez en conscience
maîtrisé lui vous allez pouvoir
atteindre plein d'objectifs si j'ai
quelque chose de très embêtant à faire
ce qui est parfois le cas il ya des
tâches répétitives ou des choses qu'on
n'a pas envie de faire je me dis pas
quand j'aurai terminé je me posais
prendre un petit café non je cherche
quelque chose de vraiment cool
après en terme de récompenses qu une
vraie récompense quelque chose de très
bien qui va me faire extrêmement plaisir
à moi j'aime beaucoup courir en
l'occurrence a peut être aller à la
salle de sport durant une heure je sais
que c'est quelque chose que j'ai envie
de faire quotidiennement mais j'irai pas
si j'ai pas fait ça et alors là du coup
j'ai triple gratification puisque en
finissant la tâche forcément j'ai une
sorte de satisfaction personnelle
ensuite je vais là où j'ai envie d'aller
comme je fais du sport j'en ai encore un
petit stock qui fait du bien à moins
bien sûr aussi de forcer son cerveau à
nous donner de l'endorphine c'est de se
donner des défis à chaque fois qu'on
réalise un défi que s'est donné le
cerveau fait un petit open bar et là
vous comprenez pourquoi je lance et le
mental l'oeil j'espère vous avoir fait
bien prendre conscience de ça puisque
quand on comprend le mécanisme
on peut l'utiliser c'est toujours
l'intérêt de comprendre les choses si tu
comprends le game alors tu peux utiliser
les règles à ton avantage pour être plus
performant on pourrait plus heureux ou
pour être plus tout ce que tu veux et je
me mets à vous tutoyez alors que je vous
vois ça n'a pas de sens j'espère donc
cette vidéo vous a plu si elle vous a
plu vous pouvez faire la fête à mon
cerveau à coups d'oeufs par rabat vous
pouvez également laisser un petit
commentaire je me fais un plaisir de
lire tous les jours tout le temps hier
amy de la chaîne et nîmes et que pro am
une vidéo sur sa chaîne
elle m'avait invité chez elle au mois
d'août pour faire une vidéo elle a
publié hier si vous voulez la regarde et
foncez c'est en ligne depuis hier 16
heures et si c'est pas déjà fait
attention parce que je sais qu'il y en a
c'est le cas vous pouvez vous abonner
avant de partir en attendant le mental
valls et une vidéo par jour pendant un
an du 1er janvier au 31 décembre ils
vont rester 85 je crois
rendez vous demain à 17h ciao